[Music]
[Applause]
steve palazzolo our good buddy senior
analyst at pro football focus co-host of
pro football focused nfl podcast he
joins us on the program
uh
best roster talent right now going into
this season is who steve
that is the buffalo bills i think when
you look at the
the bills and what they have built and
adding von miller to the mix i think
they have look when you're building
around a young quarterback the bills are
like the blueprint right now for how to
build around josh allen with the wide
receiver talent with stefan diggs with
gabriel davis and von miller comes in to
add to that defensive line and once
trudeau's white gets healthy at
cornerback i think there's a reason why
a lot of people have the bills as the
favorite for the super bowl because uh
they're pretty good all around okay but
is there a drop big drop-off between one
and two with roster talent
no i mean i think i think the top five
is is pretty close when you look at a
team like the bucks you know i think
people might be sleeping on the box
because tom brady took a little vacation
during training camp and rob gronkowski
retired but you still bring in julio
jones all of the other receiver talent
you know a couple questions on the
offensive line but the bucks are up
there
the chiefs are still up there even
though there's some question marks there
the packers are still good i just think
those other teams just have more
question marks when it comes to top to
bottom talent than a team like the bills
but you look at the kansas city chiefs
and they've prided themselves on having
a great receiving core you lose tyree
kill
kansas city fans look at that offense
and what are they going to think this
year
i think they'll take a step back before
they take a step forward you know i
think there's there'll be some growing
pains with juju smith schuster with you
know the rookie skye moore
uh with marcos valdez scaling trying to
replace some of the deep threat that
tyreek hill was but the chiefs made a
decision to be better everywhere you
know just to have a better roster rather
than just a great receiving core so i
think it's going to show up on the
defensive side of the ball the two
rookies george karloftis in the first
round trent mcduffie at corner uh both
of those guys should improve that team
but i think the offense takes a bit of a
step back there'll be some games where
the chiefs might be saying man we could
use a big play we could use that you
know 10-yard pass that turned into a
60-yard touchdown that tyree kill
brought to the table but i think the
chiefs in the long term are going to be
a better team uh because they
essentially replace tired kill with five
players but it might yeah the offense
might not be as explosive this season
talk me out of picking the chargers for
the super bowl
no that's who i picked on the pff nfl
podcast this week that was my no i said
they'd go through the wild card round
but listen here's what how i would talk
you out of it or myself i've been hyping
the chargers for the last 10 years you
know they're like the the offseason you
and me both i've been doing this i i
i've been punished i've been hurt i've
been let down
uh they're the off-season darlings but
they do let us down with some crazy but
i think brandon staley's changing it
she's changing the mentality they're
gonna be aggressive we know they're
going to go four in a fourth down
they're going to maximize possessions
justin herbert's balling and you add
khalil mack to the mix you added jc
jackson i think that team is really set
up for success uh
boy
more likely
well the rams make the super bowl or
they don't make the playoffs more likely
oh i'd say
let me say uh rims make the super bowl
but just because the the nfc is not
nearly as deep as the afc um i do think
the nfc west is is strong with the 49ers
there in the in the cardinals but um i
think that the the elites of the nfc the
packers and bucks and the rams i i just
i think they're going to be there at the
end whereas in the nfc at the afc i
think you're looking at some of these
you know if the bengals didn't make the
playoffs would we be all that surprised
maybe not just because it's so deep in
the afc so i think the nfc has a a a
little bit tighter path for the end
where the rams could make the super bowl
again he's a senior analyst at pro
football focus and co-host of the pro
football focus nfl podcast steve
palozzolo joining us i look at the
rosters with the eagles i look at the
rosters with the cardinals and also the
raiders and my big question mark is
quarterback
and maybe i shouldn't have as much of a
question mark with kyler murray as i do
with the other but
am i wrong in that that i should
you know does pro football focus how do
they look at jalen hurts uh derek carr
and kyler murray
i mean i think when you're looking at
the best quarterbacks in the league and
you're looking at is is quarterback a
question mark you're trying to say is
this guy a top eight guy that i can
believe in every single year and if
you're asking is kyler murray there yet
maybe not you know i think he was top
eight ish last year certainly dropped
off the second half of the year but he's
gotten better every single season i feel
confident in kyler murray at least
putting the cardinals in
think derek position to
probably on the fringe of that kind of
uh how i thought matthew stafford had
been for his 10 plus years in detroit
nobody was saying matt nobody should
have been saying matthew stafford was a
top 10 quarterback of his era because
there was a pretty distinct top eight or
nine but once those guys retired
stafford could kind of slide in there i
think carr has that ability and carr
plus devante adams now i think we're
going to see fireworks there i think the
raiders have the playmakers that derek
carr could have one of his best seasons
and we're going to revisit that halfway
through the year and be like man this
guy's on pace for 5 000 yards and 40
touchdowns maybe he's better than we
thought um and the jaylen hertz one is
fascinating because i think the eagles
have taken advantage of the fact that he
is on this rookie contract they could go
on draft night and say what's better to
come out of the first round than with an
aj brown than with a game-changing wide
receiver and that's going to make
devante smith last year's first round
receiver all the better that's going to
make this running game that they turned
to around week six or seven last year
that's gonna make the run game plus the
ability to win through the air you know
they just have more flexibility on
offense so i think they've done a great
job building around jalen hurts now it's
a matter of okay can you go win games
for us that is a big question mark still
for the eagles though okay how do you
rate gauge
uh trey lance because you don't have a
large sample size so how does pro
football focus look at him this season
yeah for me it's just looking at his
skill set and trying to project what's
gonna happen there and the two big
things for me is uh the 49ers with jimmy
garoppolo had one of the most efficient
passing attacks in the nfl and they did
it without a lot of
downfield passes jimmy garoppolo had one
of our lowest big time thrill rates so
those special throws down the field but
he was still number two in the nfl in
yards per attempt meaning there's open
receivers there's yards after the catch
there's a great system in place trey
lance has the ability to make those big
time throws he has the ability to throw
the ball 40 plus yards down the field
and stretch the field in a way that kyle
shanahan has not in a long time and then
you add trey lance's rushing ability and
the shanahans are just known for making
life difficult for defenses when it
comes to the run game you add in a run
threat like trey lance and there's a
million different things that the niners
can do so i feel like trey lance has a
skill set that even if he has some
growing pains even if he's not making
every perfect read or not as efficient
as jimmy garoppolo throw for throw trey
lance can add big playability both
through the air and on the ground and
that makes the 49ers pretty scary with
kyle shanahan calling the plays
your concerns about dak prescott are
the last time
we saw dak prescott without amari cooper
so right in the middle of the 2018
season
and there was a point in dak's career
where he was he was dropping off he had
a good rookie year he had two seasons
after that where for us pff grades he
ranked around 19th or 20th and then
amari cooper showed up and once he had
dak those good receivers around him his
production went through the roof and
he's been consistent and part that
probably some of it just is just his
regular development but
dak hasn't had
a non-top three receiving core in years
so he had he's had this incredible
supporting cast offensive line plus
receivers now you've got three new
starters on the offensive line you have
noah mari cooper cd lamb can step up
into that spot but you have an injured
michael gallop trying to come back the
cowboys have been at their best with an
excellent top five-ish type of offensive
line and a top three type of receiving
group and we don't have that this year
for dallas so for me it's the supporting
cast and can dak elevate the rest of
that roster because we haven't really
seen him need to do that in in four or
five years now the worst roster
talent-wise is located where
i i think it's between chicago or
houston you know i think
both teams are rebuilding you know
chicago it's probably the bears just
because they legitimately gutted that
roster um the texans they waited for the
whole desean watson thing and then they
started to add talent back to the roster
they started to but chicago has
questions on the offensive line out wide
at receiver uh all of their defensive
play makers are young or in their first
couple years roquan smith you know might
be the guy that they're gonna build
around but he's a linebacker so i think
it's the bears you know it's year two of
justin fields and unfortunately i don't
know that we're gonna get a great gauge
for what fields can do just because the
whole supporting cast is is certainly
not there but but i get it ryan pulse
had to come in he had a salary cap he
had salary cap issues they didn't have a
ton of draft picks and they're starting
to build it up from scratch in chicago
have fun tonight always great to talk to
you thank you steve
thanks dan happy football happy football
absolutely steve palazzolo